I'm excited I think we make a good team
Bella Nikki and Brie Bella just took
twinning to a whole other level and
Congrats are in order because they're
both pregnant the world comes serve
dinner table
that's right Nikki is expecting her
first child with fiance Artem he's
amazing he is just he makes me really
happy which is cool and Brie is
expecting her second child with her
hubby Daniel the two are already parents
to two-year-old daughter birdie-birdie
does need a sibling but it makes me so
nervous to do it all over again and
that's not even the best part
get this the sisters are due a week and
a half apart you can't make this stuff
up people brie and I both are on just
this incredible journey the reality
stars and professional wrestlers
announced the happy news on Wednesday
and Nikki tells People magazine that she
and Artem weren't exactly trying to get
pregnant
quote it was a total surprise it took
even me a good week to come to terms
with like oh my gosh I'm pregnant
I'm not ready for it as for brie she
said that after seven to eight months of
trying to have a second baby she was
convinced that her daughter was meant to
be an only child then BOOM bun in the
oven that's where your dedication starts
guys even their pregnancy symptoms are
twinning brie explained quote we have
definitely felt better in our lives it's
actually crazy because we both have the
same symptoms so we've been super
nauseous Nikki added that it felt like
having a hangover every day
Wow I think what mothers do is the most
beautiful thing they fully sacrifice
their body they sacrifice their life
they sacrifice some portions of their
career I think dad's too but what a mom
does for a child and it's not like over
once you give birth these sisters really
do go through all of it together when ET
caught up with Nikki and Brie in 2019
before Artem popped the question
Nikki said her sister put her man
through the wringer it took me a while
right thank you but I do I approve he's
so sweet
Bertie loves him
it's funny cuz on our podcast that's
this one say we have Artem on as a guest
which I was very nervous about and the
questions she asked I was like I can't
believe your ask me but she talks about
some stories of what Abbey she used to
be to him like I mean she put him
through a lot you is my opinion yeah and
maybe sisters the person you're welcome
for protecting well and for caring to be
protective and Nikki
well she's come a long way back in 2017
she admitted to et that watching her
sister juggle career life and motherhood
wasn't exactly giving her baby fever oh
it's actually been the best I don't know
if I would say birth control really
being with Brie's the first person I've
gotten to see like for the day-to-day
and it truly made me think like I love
being spontaneous I left my career and I
don't I don't want to be a mom something
tells me that Nikki is going to be the
cutest little momma in WWE history and
I'm willing to bet my paycheck that
these twins will hook us up with the
most adorable newborn baby photo shoot
when the stork drops off those babes of
course you can count on ET to bring you
all that and more from the Bella Twins
so make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stephens
bye for now
[Music]